so much has happened over the last few days
and one of those things is that a plant from
a totally whacked out extremist group called
LA roof pack ask the crazy question at an
Alexandria Cossio Cortez town hall.
And the whole point of it was to make people
who believe in climate change look crazy and
the reactions from the right have been incredibly
laughable, but also almost concerning and
how pathological they are.
Let me explain it all to you.
LaRouche Pak has been around a long time.
It's associated with a guy named Lyndon LaRouche
who died about eight months ago.
It's a wacky group.
You can research it.
You'll very quickly figure out how crazy the
group is.
They are now a pro Trump group that is skeptical
of climate change.
Alexandria Ocozzio Cortez had a town hall
in Queens, New York city, so they thought,
let's send someone there, let's have them
act crazy and we'll make people who believe
in climate change look really, really bad.
So they send in a woman wearing a tee shirt
that says save the planet, eat the children
to get up and to ask a question and to say,
Hey, we need to really save the planet.
We need to start eating babies.
And Alexandria Ocozzio Cortez reacts the way
a normal person would react.
When you see someone that could be completely
unstable, you can't tell.
And what you do is you don't react much at
all in order to avoid further escalating them.
Take a look at what went down, including the
question.
And AOC is a reaction.
Oh, because of the climate crisis, we only
have a few months left.
I love that you support the green deal, but
it's not getting it.
You know, getting rid of fossil fuel is not
going to solve the problem fast enough.
A Swedish professor saying that, Oh, we can
eat.
Yeah, that people, but that's not fast enough.
So I think your next campaign slogan has to
be this.
We got to start eating babies.
We don't have enough time.
There's too much seal tool.
All of you, you're, you're, you know, you're
a pollutant.
Too much seal to we have to start now, please.
You are so great.
I'm so happy that you are really supported
a new great deal.
But it's not enough.
You know, even if he would bomb Russia, we
still have too many people, too much pollution.
So we have to get rid off the babies.
That's a big problem.
Just stopping.
Hey babies aside and now we need to eat the
babies.
This is very sous.
No, thank you.
Thank you.
We'll go ahead.
Okay.
No, we'll, we'll go ahead.
No, no, no.
Thank you.
So I think, um, yeah, no.
So one of the things that's very important
to us is that we need to treat the climate
crisis with the urgency that it does present.
So as the woman was eventually, I believe
escorted out because people in the room could
tell something is clearly wrong with this
person and her presence is making everyone
uncomfortable.
AOC starts giving some general answer about
climate change and there are Trumpists and
right-wingers who have the nerve to say, why
didn't AOC denounced baby eating?
Why didn't AOC say no, we shouldn't eat babies
and children are you people this stupid?
I mean seriously criticize AOC for policy.
Criticize her because you think she's wrong
about this or that political position.
Criticize her for something that makes sense
but she didn't properly denounce baby eating
and answered it as if it were a normal question
this person was eat from now we know it was
a plant but from the second she starts talking
it's either a plant or someone who is so mentally
ill that you don't want to do anything that
could even possibly agitate them.
And AOC did exactly the right thing when people
approached me on the subway or wherever and
something is very clearly wrong with them
or they are furious and it's, it just doesn't
make any sense.
And you can't tell is this person dangerous?
Is this person mentally ill?
I can't tell.
And they spout some government conspiracy
theory.
Do you think I respond to them about the specifics
of the conspiracy that they are touting?
No, you do what you can to deescalate.
And initially it was believed that this was
merely a mentally ill person.
It was later found out that it was someone
from LaRouche PAC.
They might also be mentally ill.
They've been doing this, eat the children
thing elsewhere.
Uh, there is a picture, there's actually a
number of pictures of people wearing the exact
same tee shirts, canvassing out on the streets.
So AOC did the right thing.
She handled it correctly, stopped being losers
and go complain about something else.
I mean seriously and you know, I don't know,
sometimes this is concern trolling where the
right wingers and the Trump is who are saying,
Oh my goodness, AOC didn't even have the decency
to denounce baby eating.
Sometimes they're not being genuine.
It's concern trolling.
They're pretending to be worried.
Could AOC maybe actually be in favor of baby
eating or does AOC may be really think that
baby eating is a way to save the planet or
whatever.
I actually think that there are some trumpets
that are so diluted and so malignantly disconnected
from the realities of how to deal with people
in the real world that they're not concerned
trolling when they say, why didn't AOC denounced
the baby eating?
They are actually so disconnected from reality
that they just see evil.
They see wrongdoing, they see misdeeds in
everything, in everything.
That some something like a, somebody like
AOC does.
And that's why you can't convince those people
to change their mind and vote the right way
in November of 2020.
That is why we have to go around them or through
them, not with them to defeat Donald Trump
in November of 2020.
It's sad, but
it's the reality.